ahora que ya sabemos cómo dibujar
estructuras de puntos de louis
apliquemos las reglas al año nitrato
podemos dibujar diferentes estructuras
para este año que se conocen como
estructuras de resonancia primero
necesitamos calcular los electrones de
valencia entonces como el nitrógeno se
encuentra en el grupo 5 de la tabla
periódica
aquí tenemos 5 electrones de valencia y
como el oxígeno se encuentra en el grupo
aquí tenemos 6 electrones de valencia
por cada oxígeno y como tenemos 3
oxígenos 6 por 3 es igual a 18
electrones de valencia más 5 que tenemos
de nitrógeno nos da un total de 23
observen que tenemos una carga negativa
es un año así que agregamos un electrón
23 más
uno es igual a 24 electrones de valencia
que vamos a colocar en nuestra
estructura de puntos de louis
sabemos que el nitrógeno será el átomo
central porque el oxígeno es más electro
negativo ahí está ya representamos 246
electrones de valencia por lo tanto 24
menos 6
nos falta colocar 18 electrones y
podemos empezar en los átomos terminales
en los oxígenos para que cumplan con la
regla del octeto entonces cada oxígeno
ya tiene 2 electrones a su alrededor que
hemos resaltado de color rosa así que
cada oxígeno necesita 6 electrones más
para completar su octeto
cada oxígeno ya está rodeado por 8
electrones los oxígenos están felices y
como agregamos 6 electrones de valencia
a 3 oxígenos 6 por 3 es igual a 18 ya
colocamos todos los electrones en
nuestra estructura ahora ya dijimos que
los oxígenos están felices pero qué pasa
con el nitrógeno bueno observen que el
nitrógeno solo tiene 6 electrones a su
alrededor los electrones de color rosa y
como el nitrógeno también quiere
completar su objeto hay muchas formas en
que podemos ayudarlo por ejemplo podemos
tomar este par de electrones libres y
moverlos hacia acá para compartirlos
entre el oxígeno y el nitrógeno entonces
tenemos el nitrógeno
unido con un doble enlace al oxígeno de
arriba que tenía tres pares de
electrones libres pero ahora sólo tiene
dos porque los electrones en verde se
movieron para formar el doble enlace del
lado izquierdo tenemos otro oxígeno
y del lado derecho tenemos otro está es
una estructura pero vamos a ponerla
entre corchetes para indicar la carga
negativa
esta es una posible estructura y si en
lugar de mover un par de electrones del
oxígeno de arriba movemos estos
electrones en azul podemos dibujar otra
estructura ahora tenemos un doble enlace
con el oxígeno de la izquierda que tenía
tres pares de electrones libres pero
ahora solo tiene dos y tenemos un enlace
simple con el oxígeno de arriba que
vuelve a tener sus tres pares de
electrones libres y no olvidemos al
oxígeno que tenemos a la derecha con
tres pares de electrones libres
esta es otra estructura y vamos a poner
los corchetes con la carga negativa
finalmente otra opción sería tomar un
par de electrones de este oxígeno de la
derecha nos queda el nitrógeno unido con
un doble enlace al oxígeno de la derecha
que ahora sólo tiene dos pares de
electrones libres después tenemos un
oxígeno hacia arriba con tres pares de
electrones libres al igual que el
oxígeno de la izquierda esta es otra
posible estructura estas tres
estructuras se consideran estructuras de
resonancia que se representan con una
flecha de doble sentido cuando los
estudiantes ven las estructuras de
resonancia piensan que el ión va
cambiando a cualquiera de estas tres
estructuras pero en realidad necesitamos
combinar las tres estructuras para
obtener un libre
de resonancia que nos dé una mejor idea
de la estructura del guión
entonces dibujemos una representación
sencilla del librito de resonancia si
combinamos las tres estructuras en una
sola observen que en todas las
estructuras tenemos un doble enlace con
alguno de los oxígenos con el de arriba
con el de la izquierda y con el de la
derecha
así que si tratamos de juntarlas en una
sola estructura podemos decir que los
electrones están deslocalizados entre
los tres oxígenos así que en lugar de
poner un doble enlace por ejemplo entre
el nitrógeno y el oxígeno de arriba
podemos mostrar que los electrones están
deslocalizados entonces tenemos un
enlace más fuerte que un enlace simple
pero no tan fuerte como un doble enlace
y podemos dibujar lo mismo entre el
nitrógeno y este oxígeno los
electrones estan deslocalizados ahí está
y una forma de comprobar que el ión se
parece más a este híbrido es con la
longitud del enlace cuando se mide la
longitud de los enlaces en el guión
todos los enlaces entre el nitrógeno y
los oxígenos tienen la misma longitud en
cambio si analizamos algunas de estas
estructuras por ejemplo la primera
resulta que este doble enlace es más
pequeño que algunos de estos enlaces
simples así que en realidad tenemos un
híbrido en donde los electrones están
deslocalizados y ese es el objetivo de
dibujar las estructuras de resonancia